los océanos del mundo constituyen el 70 % del planeta,
del cual el 95 % permanece inexplorado.
Lo que intentamos hacer a través de la expedición
es construir y probar un submarino
que pueda llegar a cualquier punto en el fondo del planeta
para explorar el 60 % de este planeta que permanece inexplorado.
DB: Se necesita un instrumento útil para eso, ¿no?
VV: Correcto.
Este instrumento es el submarino, el "Limiting Factor".
Es lo último en embarcaciones,
sustentado por el buque de apoyo, el "Pressure Drop".
Tiene una esfera de titanio, 90 milímetros de espesor,
que mantiene constante la presión atmosférica,
y es capaz de sumergirse muchas veces a lo más profundo del océano.
DB: ¿Es como el SpaceX de la exploración oceánica?
VV: Sí, es un poco como el SpaceX de la exploración oceánica,
pero yo piloto mis vehículos.
(Risas)
DB: ¿Vas a llevar a Elon contigo o...?
VV: Sí, podría llevar a alguien ahí.
Elon, si estás escuchando,
te daré una vuelta en mi nave siempre que me devuelvas el favor.
(Risas)
DB: Cuéntanos cómo es bajo el agua.
Estamos hablando de un lugar donde la intensidad de la presión
se parece a la de la Torre Eiffel puesta en el pie.
VV: Es mayor aún, unas 1100 atmósferas.
Lo bueno es que tenemos una esfera de titanio
que nos permite llegar a esas profundidades extremas
y emerger varias veces.
Eso nunca se ha hecho antes.
El Challenger Deep se sumergió dos veces,
tanto en 1960 como en 2012, pilotado por James Cameron.
Eran embarcaciones experimentales que se sumergieron y emergieron.
Este es el primer sumergible certificado comercialmente
capaz de sumergirse y emerger miles de veces con dos personas,
incluso un científico.
Nos enorgullece haber llevado, hace solo tres semanas,
al británico que realizó la inmersión más profunda de la historia,
el Dr. Alan Jamieson de la Universidad de Newcastle,
que fue con nosotros a la fosa de Java.
DB: Entonces, siento que hay poco que te asuste.
VV: Pues, el buceo es muy diferente.
Si sufren de claustrofobia, no les gustará estar en el submarino.
Nos sumergimos a lo profundo del mar
y las misiones suelen durar 8 o 9 h en un espacio reducido.
Es muy diferente a mi profesión anterior de escalar montañas en espacios abiertos,
con el viento fuerte y el frío extremo.
Esto es lo contrario, es mucho más técnico.
Tiene que ver con la precisión de usar los instrumentos
y solucionar todo tipo de problemas.
Pero si algo sale mal en el submarino, no se enterarán de ello.
(Risas)
DB: Quieres decir que tienes miedo de encontrar goteras.
VV: Sí, eso no es bueno, pero tener goteras no es del todo malo
porque si lo fuera, no lo sabrían...
(Risas)
Tampoco sería bueno si la cápsula estuviera en llamas,
pero es un sumergible muy seguro.
Suelo decir que no confío en muchas cosas en la vida,
pero confío en el titanio, la matemática y el análisis de elementos finitos,
lo que nos lleva a determinar
si estas cosas pueden sobrevivir en condiciones y presiones extremas.
DB: La fabricación de esa esfera es perfecta, ¿no?
Esta es una nave verdaderamente única.
VV: El desafío central fue construir una esfera de titanio
con una exactitud de un 0,1% de la máquina.
Es difícil trabajar con el titanio
y mucha gente no ha logrado hacerlo, pero nosotros tuvimos mucha suerte.
Nuestro extraordinario equipo creó una esfera casi perfecta,
que, sometida a presiones, es la geometría más fuerte que se podría tener.
Cuando estoy en el sumergible y se cierra la escotilla,
estoy seguro de que me sumergiré y volveré a emerger.
DB: ¿Verificas dos veces si se ha cerrado la escotilla?
VV: Solo hay dos reglas para sumergir un submarino.
La primera es asegurar la escotilla, y la segunda es volver a la primera regla.
(Risas)
DB: Entonces, estuvieron en el océano Atlántico.
En el océano Antártico también.
VV: Nadie jamás se ha sumergido en el océano Antártico antes y sé por qué.
Es sumamente hostil, el clima es horrible.
La palabra 'colisión' me viene a la mente.
Pero lo exploramos también.
Me alegré cuando se acabó.
DB: Sí... VV: Gracias.
(Aplausos)
DB: Es como si lo exploraras con gran prisa.
Y ahora el océano Índico, como mencionó Kelly.
VV: Sí, fue hace tres semanas.
Tuvimos la suerte de resolver el misterio.
Si me hubieran preguntado hace tres semanas:
"Cuál es el punto más profundo del océano Índico?",
nadie lo habría sabido.
Había dos posibilidades:
una, cerca de Australia Occidental, y otra, en la fosa de Java.
Tenemos una maravillosa nave con un excelente sonar.
Mapeamos ambas, enviamos sondas al fondo y verificamos.
Está en la parte central de la fosa de Java,
donde nadie pensaba que se situase.
Cada vez que concluíamos una de nuestras inmersiones importantes,
debíamos correr a editar Wikipedia porque está por completo desactualizada.
(Risas)
DB: ¿Es probable que pasen más tiempo descendiendo que explorando?
VV: No, en realidad, pasamos bastante tiempo ahí.
Tengo cuatro días de suministro de oxígeno en la embarcación.
Si estoy ahí por cuatro días y algo sale mal, probablemente no lo use,
pero tarda más o menos tres horas en llegar a lo más profundo del océano.
Normalmente podemos pasar tres o cuatro horas ahí
y tres horas más para emerger.
No deben permanecer bajo el agua por más de 10 u 11 h.
Puede ser un poco apretado.
DB: Bueno, háblanos del fondo del océano Índico.
¿Nadie jamás lo ha visto antes, aparte de ti?
VV: Estas son imágenes de uno de nuestros aterrizadores robóticos.
En la parte inferior derecha, se puede ver un "assfish" robusto,
así se llama.
(Risas)
Pero a la izquierda pueden notar una criatura nunca antes vista:
una medusa del fondo del mar llamada ascidia con pedúnculo.
Ninguna de las medusas ha tenido jamás tal apariencia.
Tiene una cría en la base de su pedúnculo, y se está desplazando bellamente.
En cada inmersión,
a pesar de estar ahí abajo por solo unas horas,
encontramos tres o cuatro nuevas especies
pues son lugares que han estado aislados por miles de millones de años
y ningún ser humano jamás ha estado ahí para grabarlas
ni para tomar muestras.
Esto es extraordinario para nosotros.
(Aplausos)
Lo que esperamos,
el objetivo principal de nuestra misión, es construir una herramienta:
una puerta con la que lograremos potencialmente crear más de ellas
y llevar a científicos ahí para realizar miles de inmersiones,
para abrir esa puerta a la exploración
y descubrir formas de vida que ni siquiera sabíamos que existieran.
DB: Más personas han viajado al espacio que al fondo del océano.
Eres una de las tres.
Vas a permitir que ese número aumente.
VV: Tres personas se han sumergido al fondo del océano Pacífico:
el batiscafo Trieste, en 1960, con dos tripulantes,
y James Cameron, en 2012, con el Deep Sea Challenger.
Gracias Jim, excelente submarino.
Esta es una tecnología de tercera generación.
No solo intentaremos sumergirnos en dos semanas,
sino que intentaremos hacerlo varias veces,
lo cual nunca se ha hecho antes.
Si conseguimos hacerlo, habremos puesto a prueba la tecnología
y no solo abriremos la puerta, sino que permanecerá abierta.
(Aplausos)
DB: Fantástico. Mucha suerte.
VV: Muchas gracias. DB: Gracias a ti.
VV: Gracias a todos.
(Aplausos)